Are you telling me the crown is three million
in debt?
Actually it's twenty trillion.
How could you let this happen?
Entitlement spending, a bunch of wars,
that bullet train to Riverrun didn't help.
That is a big wall.
And on the other side are the free folk?
No, over here, we call them wildlings.
Right, and we hate them, because why?
Because they are a savage, backwards, knuckle-dragging
people.
They do whatever they please, they marry who
they want, they pay no taxes,
do you know they don't even have a real king?
Just some guy they voluntarily choose to follow.
They're savages.
So they built that wall-
No, we built the wall.
Hodor [Repeated]
China [Repeated]
As the Invisible Hand of the King,
can I just suggest, once again, that we do
nothing?
Westeros is a shit show.
We're massively in debt, people are starving,
we're constantly at war,
there's an oppressive surveillance apparatus,
and stifling religious dogma encroaching on
matters of state,
and draconian border restrictions.
I mean, at this point I think it's fairly
clear that we suck at this governing thing,
right?
I am the King!
Again with the king stuff.
And in that vault is the Social Security Trust
Fund,
where all of the money goes that will one
day be paid out to retirees.
Nothing.
Yeah, it's pretty much a Ponzi scheme.
We all agree that winter is coming but the
answer lies in innovation,
not in rationing wood and coal.
Baratheons,
sigil: a stag,
words: ours is the fury.
Good.
The Democrats,
sigil: a donkey,
words:
it was Russia's fault?
No, a common saying but not their official
motto.
There's always a victim.
Republicans,
sigil: an elephant,
words: hold my beer.
No.
War, walls and Bibles?
Well, what do they believe?
I don't feel like I even know them anymore.
You do know them, think.
9/11.
Libertarians,
words: maximizing individual liberty and minimizing
statist incursions
through a robust deployment of the non-aggression
principle.
And the sigil is a porcupine humping a pile
of money.
No swords, no daggers, no crossbows,
no dark magic ghost babies.
Some jackass blows up a sept and now we all
gotta take our shoes off.
The night is dark and full of terrorists.
If you have more than six ounces of wildfire,
you must place it in a transparent plastic
baggie.
Trial by combat will be forbidden throughout
the seven kingdoms.
The tradition is a brutish one.
Right, but minimum sentencing for non-violent
drug offenders,
that's still a thing.
Good people don't use milk of the poppy.
God, you're such an asshole.
I, I don't know,
I just think blowing up a sept in the middle
of your trial feels like,
obstruction of justice.
So we built that wall,
Yeah.
and we paid for it
Oh yeah.
to keep out the free folk
Right.
and their redheads
Uh huh.
and now we're on this side of the wall.
Yeah.
Is there like a door?
There's probably a big door.
There's probably
a door.
It shouldn't take a low income Dothraki four
years to get a hair braiding license.
It's absurd.
For the watch.
Peer pressure.
Does due process mean nothing to you people?
I don't care, the unsullied can use whatever
bathroom they want.
Why do we need to get involved in this?
Joffrey, Circei, Walder Frey...
Jeff Sessions, Chuck Schumer, The House Financial
Services Committee...
The names of every fucking person in Westeros.
Only the ones I'm going to kill.
That's what we're doing?!
Do- No, I was just gonna write a letter.
That's fucked up Arya.
Things don't have to be planned in order to
be orderly.
Complex systems can evolve from natural behavior,
and the result is more effective and more
efficient
than anything created by a central planner.
Individual liberty, is a more powerful tool
for prosperity, than any army, any dragon,
or any king could ever be.
I really thought this was the libertarian
moment.
Make Westeros great again.
No.
Grab 'em by the poppy?
Big government if it's our government?
No.
Orange is the new black?
Put a flag on it.
No.
Technically Lincoln was a Republican.
For the children.
No.
From each according to his ability, to each
according to his need.
No.
Something something social justice?
Social justice in all caps.
No.
Social justice exclamation mark.
Are we playing a game?